si las autoridades de marruecos han
confirmado la muerte de 18 personas
migrantes pero la asociación marroquí de
derechos humanos ha podido documentar al
menos 37 fallecidos entre los que habría
también dos agentes de policía por otra
parte sigue habiendo decenas de heridos
de gravedad según la versión policial
los migrantes murieron asfixiados en una
avalancha en la parte marroquí de la
frontera tras duros enfrentamientos con
la policía en las imágenes que se han
difundido se aprecia que las fuerzas
marroquíes emplearon una violencia
brutal contra los migrantes y ahora la
asociación marroquí de derechos humanos
exige que se abra una investigación para
esclarecer lo ocurrido a pesar de la
represión unas 150 personas lograron
acceder al enclave español de melilla y
otras a 70 fueron expulsadas en caliente
por parte de la guardia civil española y
este episodio de muerte en la frontera
de melilla llega en un contexto de
incremento de la represión hacia
migrantes y refugiados aquí en marruecos
cabe recordar que tanto españa como la
unión europea pagan anualmente
cantidades millonarias de dinero
para que impida que estas personas
migrantes y refugiadas puedan acercarse
a la frontera española en las
asociaciones de defensa de derechos
humanos sobre el terreno denuncian que
la violencia en esta frontera euro
africana no ha hecho más que aumentar
desde que españa y marruecos se
resolvieran en abril la que fue su mayor
crisis diplomática en 20 años